Jules vapes pens ، كلها
أنظمة توصيل النيكوتين الإلكترونية للسجائر الإلكترونية ، يقول البعض إنها
بديل أكثر أمانًا للتدخين ، ويقول آخرون
إنها تمثل خطرًا جديدًا ، لكن ما
هو الفرق حقًا بين
vaping والتدخين جيدًا عندما
تشعل سيجارة؟  تقوم بإعادة حرق مزيج من
أوراق التبغ ومئات المكونات الأخرى
في تلك اللحظة ، حيث تقوم بإنشاء
أكثر من 7000 مادة كيميائية من
المعروف أن بعضها يسبب السرطان والبعض الآخر
سامة تعمل هذه السجائر عن طريق
تسخين محلول يُعرف أحيانًا باسم
عصير vape أو سائل في  بخار هو
عادة النيكوتين أو الحشيش الممزوج
بمكثفات النكهات المضافة والمواد
الكيميائية الأخرى الآن ، تعتبر بعض هذه الإضافات
مثل المنكهات
آمنة بشكل عام للأكل من قبل إدارة الغذاء والدواء ، لكننا
لا نعرف ما إذا كانت آمنة للاستنشاق
وهذا أمر بالغ الأهمية  قد يكون
لاستنشاق هذه المواد الكيميائية بدلاً من
تناولها تأثيرات مختلفة جدًا
على الجسم والتي ما زلنا لا
نفهمها تمامًا
أيضًا عند استنشاق هذه المواد.
يمكن أن تسبب هذه المواد
تهيجًا وحتى التهابًا في رئتيك
على عكس السجائر الإلكترونية التي لا تترك
وراءها نفس بقايا التبغ
التي تساهم في سرطان الرئة أو الحلق
ولكنها تحتوي على
أملاح النيكوتين التي هي شكل مركّز من
المادة المسببة للإدمان في  في الواقع ،
يمكن لحجرة صغيرة واحدة فقط أن تنقل قدرًا كبيرًا من
النيكوتين مثل علبة السجائر ،
ويقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) إن الأبخرة قد تستنشق أيضًا
معادن ثقيلة مثل النيكل أو الرصاص ، لذا
من الصعب تحديد مدى خطورة سجائرنا جيدًا لأنها
الأيام الأولى وما زال هناك  يدرس الكثير
من علماء البيانات الآن
الروابط المحتملة بين vaping وأمراض الرئة
والنوبات
وتأثير vaping --zz على الإدمان ولكن تذكر أن الأمر
استغرق عقودًا من البيانات عن التدخين قبل
أن نعرف المخاطر الحقيقية
للسجائر وربما عقودًا أخرى قبل ذلك.  نعرفها
سيجارة
بسبب جسدك